apiculture maraîchage élevage de
volailles bienvenue à la ferme des clots
de bonnel c'est ici que le groupement
des agriculteurs biologiques a rassemblé
le 19 juin dernier les agriculteurs
d'île de france autour d'une thématique
la biodiversité
une journée d'information et de
rencontre entre les professionnels
agricoles
le but de la journée c'était de
rassembler les acteurs du territoire
pour parler d'une problématique qui nous
concerne tous et qui a été dernièrement
soulevées par les agriculteurs du gab
considérant que lui même était en bio il
y avait encore des efforts à faire au
niveau des aménagements pour favoriser
la biodiversité faunistique et
floristique sur leur exploitation
au programme de la journée visite de
terrain et présentation des aménagements
mise en place par la ferme des clos avec
l'appui aussi du parc naturel de
chevreuse plan des endroits protégés
création de points d'eau installation de
parcelles aménagées pour la faune
sauvage
tout est mis en oeuvre pour permettre
une régulation naturelle des
exploitations accueil de libellules et
plantes aquatiques arrivée d'insectes
pollinisateurs tout en protégeant les
exploitations des nuisibles et cerise
sur le gâteau les agriculteurs reçoivent
des indemnisations pour compenser les
surfaces non cultivées ou en ce moment
on est vraiment dans une période de
transition où les gens veulent changer
et cei et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que sur certaines mesures on a des
réponses très positif de la biodiversité
avec des communautés d'espèces qui se
réinstallent très rapidement là on est
vraiment en phase d'installation mais
que le
projet donc notamment d'agroforesterie
c'est des projets qui sont vraiment sur
du long terme quoi céder des projets qui
vont être mis en place sur plusieurs
dizaines d'années peut-être que moi j'en
verrai pas le bout mais entre la mise en
place d'arbres fruitiers la mise en
place d'arbres bois d'oeuvre
effectivement c'est des projets qui
s'inscrivent sur du long terme et donc
ils vont prendre beaucoup de temps
une journée qui se termine par des
ateliers pédagogiques création de
nichoirs pour mésanges table-ronde sur
le thème les insectes pollinisateurs et
analyse de la composition du sol les
organisateurs espèrent que les
agriculteurs pourront se servir de cette
rencontre et mettre en place des
aménagements de retour sur leur
exploitation
l'objectif à terme est de démultiplier
les bonnes pratiques avec des techniques
qui font leurs preuves sur le terrain et
qui s'avère plus saine pour
l'environnement et pour le consommateur